Mein Name ist Käskin, ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Klaus Richter.
Klaus, K, L, A, U, S und Richter wie Beruf Richter.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Richter?
66 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 17. Oktober 59 geboren.
59? Können Sie bitte wieder sagen, es ist 50.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß und wiege 73 kg.
Herr Richter, was wird Sie uns tun?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit drei Monaten einen zunehmenden Husten habe.
Ist der Husten trocken oder mit Auswurf?
Er ist ja trocken, aber manchmal ist er auch blutig.
Manchmal blutig.
Trittler, Husten, Ruhe oder bei Körperleaktiven?
Beides.
Und Sie haben keinen Auswurf?
Hab ich Sie richtig verstanden?
Nee, manchmal habe ich glasigen Auswurf, aber selten.
Einmal morgens habe ich glasigen Auswurf und danach eigentlich nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Manchmal werde ich mich sehr belastet, ja.
Haben Sie Brüschsmersen?
Wenn ich stark huste, ja.
Können Sie bitte die Intensity der Schmerzen von 1 bis 10,
einschätzen, wobei 1 leicht werden und 10 unerträglichen Schmerzen entspricht.
Und 4?
Ja.
Herr Richter, möchten Sie noch etwas für uns zufügen, Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden?
Dieser Husten stört mich schon sehr, muss man sagen.
Können Sie etwas dagegen machen, um mir helfen?
Ja, ich...
Können Sie die Frage wiederholen, Entschuldigung?
Können Sie etwas für meinen Husten tun?
Dieser Husten schränkt mich in meinem Leben sehr ein.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, natürlich. Wir helfen Ihnen. Wir machen unser Bestes.
Okay.
Ich habs aber auch, ne?
Ja, angeschön.
Wir sind im Mieter.
Okay.
Hatten Sie in letzter Zeit
viele Infektionen oder waren Sie ergerthet?
Ich habe immer wieder 2-mal im Jahr eine Atemwegserkrankung.
Aber das ist jetzt unabhängig davon, glaube ich.
Herr Richter, ich hätte jetzt eine Frage zu Ihrem allgemeinen gesundheitszustand.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit viel bei Stärfrösen und Nachschweiß bemerkt?
Also, ich habe tatsächlich seit ungefähr jetzt so einem Monat starken Nachtschweiß.
Müssen Sie Ihren Schlafentzug auswechseln?
Meinen Was?
Müssen Sie Ihren Schlafentzug, Schlafkleidung auswechseln?
Ja, also manchmal muss ich mein Nachtentz auswechseln, ja.
Sie haben kein Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit?
Es ist ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ich habe abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilo und in welchem Zeit?
Also, ich habe jetzt ungefähr 8 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Seit jetzt circa 2-3 Jahren.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, gar nicht.
Wie schlafen Sie gut?
Ich nehme an, dass Sie Schlafprobleme haben, weil Sie Husteln haben.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich habe keine Einschlafen, aber ich habe Durchschlafenstörungen.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Herr Witte, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck,
Zuckerkrankheit, Asthma, Exama oder etwas?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck schon seit Jahren.
Seit wann?
Ich habe das mit 40 Jahren, also ungefähr seit 6 Jahren.
Ich habe das seit 4 Jahren.
Seit wann?
Ich habe das mit 40 Jahren, also ungefähr seit 26 Jahren.
Was noch?
Und COPD habe ich.
Sie haben schon COPD leiden.
Sie leiden an COPD.
Seit wann?
Das habe ich auch seit ungefähr 20 Jahren.
Weiterer Erkrankungen?
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, mein Blutdruck ist raus und meine geilen Blase entfernt worden.
Wann mal diese Operationen?
Also meine geilen Blase ist mit 45 Jahren entfernt worden
und meine Blinde mit 25 Jahren.
Sind Sie schon mal wegen einer anderen Erkrankung im Krankenhaus behandelt worden?
Ja, ich war schon zweimal wegen der COPD, war ich schon krank, ausgewiesen.
Herr Richter, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme für meinen Blutdruck 2 Medikamente ein.
2?
2 Medikamente, nehme ich für meinen Blutdruck ein.
Können wir wieder der Name holen?
Ja, Candesatan.
2 Milligramm?
Nein, 16 Milligramm, morgens und abends.
Und ich nehme auch Amlodipine ein, 5 Milligramm morgens und abends.
Wie viele Milligramm?
5 Milligramm Amlodipine.
Was veränden Sie gegen COPD?
Ja, ich habe 2 Sprays nicht einnimmt.
Den Namen habe ich jetzt vergessen, wie das heißt.
Und ich nehme einen Notfall Medikamente, einen Seibuttermol.
Außer diesen 2 Spray oder ein Spray ist Seibuttermol?
Nein, sonst nichts.
Also manchmal schreibt mein Haus aus mir Cortison auch, als Tabletten, wenn es mir sehr schlecht geht.
Wie viele Milligramm dieses Cortison?
10 Milligramm, aber nur für ein paar Tage.
Bei Bedarf?
Ja, nicht bei Bedarf, sondern bei ein paar Tagen, dann höre ich auch.
Herr Litte, haben Sie Allergie?
Ich habe einen Hausstopp.
Wie äußert Sie diese Allergie?
Nein.
Wie äußert Sie die Allergie?
Mit Niesen und Schnupfen und Nase laufen, Augen trennen.
Verstehe.
Herr Litte, rachen Sie?
Ich rache ja.
Wie viele Segerte rachen Sie?
Ich rache ungefähr 18, 19 Segerte am Tag.
Seit wann?
Seit 45 Jahren.
40 Jahre.
Herr Litte, haben Sie schon einmal darüber nachgedacht, wie Sie den Segertenkonsum auslösen oder reduzieren?
Mehrfach habe ich schon darüber nachgedacht.
Ich habe auch schon einmal ein, zwei Jahre aufgehört, aber ich schaffe das nicht.
Ja.
Und Herr Süho, können wir Ihnen ein Rache Entzündungsprogramm organisieren, wenn Sie möchten?
Können wir gerne machen, aber das bringt mir nichts.
Ich habe das schon mehrmals gemacht.
Okay.
Wir beenden dieses Gespräch, dann untersuchen Sie, dann sprechen wir später.
Rachen Sie, Entschuldigung, trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Litte?
Wie bitte?
Trücken Sie Alkohol.
Es ist ganz, ganz selten, vielleicht einmal im Jahr.
Können Sie drücken?
Ich drücke.
Nein.
Herr Litte, neben Ihren Eltern noch?
Beide sind verstorben.
Das tut mir leise hören.
Gibt es, oder gab es, krönche Erkrankungen bei Ihren Eltern?
Also, mein Vater ist in einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Hat man gesagt.
Und meine Mutter hatte Brustkrebs.
Brustkrebs.
Sind Sie Rentner, Herr Litte, oder arbeiten Sie?
Ja, ich bin Rentner.
Was haben Sie früher gemacht?
Ich war Maurer.
Maurer.
Ich habe auf dem Bau gearbeitet, auf der Bauarbeit.
Sind Sie verreiheitet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Gut.
Mit wem leben Sie?
Mit meiner Frau natürlich.
Mit den Kindern sonst.
Herr Litte, ich habe alle meine Fragen, ich habe Ihnen alle meine
Fragen schon gestärkt.
Möchten Sie Not, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe auch schon Konklusion genommen.
Das bringt aber auch nichts.
Und mir macht dieser blutige Brusten sehr Sorgen.
Ja, Sie haben Welt.
Aber schön, dass Sie zu uns gekommen sind.
Zuerst werde ich Sie untersuchen,
danach genutachten.
Ich habe auch noch etwas zu tun.
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
MILMA점, den ich geboren habe,
dann werde ich von derykann auf veil sec taken.
Of course, auf
Blut ist immer schlimm.
Ja, Blut ist immer schlimm.
Aber so erst müssen wir das abklingen.
Ja, das machen wir nicht.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe Kollegen noch andere Fragen oder Ergänzungen.
Darf ich etwas fragen?
Ja.
Wir haben erwähnt, dass ich manchmal aufspiel.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Blut im Auswurf ist.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie das gemerkt?
Wie war das Blut?
War es vermischt mit Auswurf?
Können Sie das erklären?
Ich habe eher glasigen Auswurf.
Aber ich habe seit zwei Wochen immer wieder Blut vermischt.
Ein Auswurf mit glasigem Auswurf.
Dankeschön.
Ein Blut im Auswurf war das erste Mal, nur zwei Wochen?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich es immer wieder.
Seit zwei Wochen.
Dankeschön.
Herr Schülegung, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit,
ich meine drei Monate oder sechs Monate
Gewichtsverlust?
Zwei Mal?
Ja, habe ich gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, Herr Schülegung,
ich habe sie in der letzten Zeit gewusst.
Danke schön.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Es geht um Herrn Glasrichter, der 6 und 6 Jahre alt ist.
Und 178 cm groß ist, er wiegt 73 kg.
Der Patient hat eine gute Erwege.
Seit drei Monaten, seit der 5.
Hand, progredient verlaufenden,
ich habe mit einem Schuput,
ich habe mit einem Schuput und eine Hemopütose vor.
Auserwärts,
der Patient über Belastungsdüsten
und Torexschmerzen beim Husten.
Die Schmerzinsensteit wurde mit 4 von 10 bewertet.
Die Bewertung der Schmerzen
ist in der ersten Zeit,
seit einer Monat,
in Appetenz,
und eine Gewichtsabnahme von 8 kg
in zwei Monaten
und in so eine Form von Durchstrafstören.
Das ist eine Art,
die ich in der ersten Zeit
habe,
und in so eine Form von Durchstrafstören.
Die Fragen nach Fieber, Schütterfroß,
wurden verneit.
In der Vorgesicht des Patienten
finden Sie
eine arterielle Hypertonie seit 26 Jahren.
Die chronische Obstruktiv-Lungen-Krankheit
seit 20 Jahren
hat Sie im Alter von 25 Jahren
eine Abendoktemie im Alter von 45 Jahren
eine Koristomie untersogen.
Auserwärts hat unser Patient
zweimal wegen COPD-Extreparationsstationen
aufgenommen.
Der Patient nimmt Kandesarter
16 Milligramm morgens und abends
1,55 Milligramm morgens und abends
erverwendet zwei Spray,
aber der Name dieser Spray ist nicht erinnerlich.
Außerdem nimmt unser Patient
gelegentlich 7 Milligramm
Cortison für ein paar Tage.
Der Patient hat eine Hausstau-Milbenallergie,
die sich mit allergie-Scher
reinitis-äußert.
Unser Patient
rat ungefähr 45 Packungsjahre.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol
und konsumiere keine Drogen.
Die Familienanamnese zeigte
den Tod bei der Eltern des Patienten.
Der Vater ist an Miokartinfarkt
verstorben, die Mutter ist
an Mama-Karstenung verstorben.
Unsere Patientin redet,
früher hat er als Maurer gearbeitet.
Er ist verreiratet und hat zwei
gesunde Kinder und lebt mit ihrer Frau.
Die Anamnestischen, ja,
haben Sie Fragen? Seiner Frau.
Ja, seine Frau.
Die Anamnestischen angaben deuten
am ersten auf Bronscheer Karstenung hin.
Die Bronscheer Diagnostik kommen,
die sie auf die Kinder sind.
Was könnte sein?
Ich erinnere mich in der Fernseher Bergnose.
Die Fernseher kommen,
wer fragrance.
Und, was könnte sein?
Unser Patient hat schon
und eine gewisse Abnahme und in der Patenz. Deshalb habe ich diese Verderstdiagnose.
Aber natürlich könnte andere Erkrankungen als Ursachen sein.
Soweit abgerüht, zuerst würde ich die Witterparameter bestimmen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten und Körper untersuchen.
Bei der Untersuchung fokussiere ich natürlich die Lunge.
Ich speziere und ausgütze dann Papiere die Lunge.
Ich veranlasse den Röntgen Torax.
Bei unklaren Befund im Röntgen Torax veranlasse ich eine City Torax.
Ja.
Ich kann auch veranlasse die Lunge untersuchen.
Schön.
Welche Lunge untersuchen?
Ja.
Große Spritbild. CRP als Entzündungsparameter.
Und Nenemberte, Leberwerte, Elektrolyte, TSH und für Auszuschließen.
Welche Lunge untersuchen?
Ich würde erst abwarten, was beim Röntgen rauskommt.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt uns Fragen.
Einfacher Fall.